First things first.
Time to go fishing.
I hope to get
some-- some eels.
Some eels?
Yeah, a Conger eel.
We have big conger eels here.
GORDON RAMSEY (VOICEOVER):
Of course, David wants
to go fishing for conger eels.
They're powerful and
enormous, just like David's
competitive Croatian spirit.
Is that yours?
Yes.
Yes, it's my beauty.
That is a beautiful boat.
Thank you.
Oh, I'm so excited, honestly.
You're not going fishing
from my sailing boat.
What?
We're not going fishing
from my sailing boat.
We're going fishing
with my father.
Stop it.
In that dingy?
Yeah.
It's a traditional
way of fishing.
Yeah, but hold on a minute.
Ah, this is for joy-- for fun.
But let's talk about
comfortable first.
Is that really your father?
Yeah.
Good morning.
Welcome.
Good to see you.
Are you serious we're
going fishing in that?
Yes.
There's me thinking
we're on this
beautiful, glamorous
sailboat that belongs
to David and his family.
But no, [bleep] he wants me
to become Croatian quickly.
Should we set sail?
Or set sink?
GORDON RAMSEY (VOICEOVER):
People told me
Croatia was like Italy, but none
of my vacations on Amalfi Coast
had me fishing in a boat not
much bigger than a bathtub.
David's dad set a
line of baited hooks
at dawn to hopefully
catch a conger eel.
Just be careful for the hooks.
Big hooks.
Be very careful.
It's a dangerous thing.
GORDON RAMSEY: (VOICEOVER)
[bleep] This line has
100 hooks set 3 meters apart.
[bleep] Big hooks.
Grab the wrong spot and
you've gone from fisherman
to catch of the day.
Little bend on your
knees so it will be easier.
Gotcha.
It's a work out and a half.
Yep.
It's good for your shoulders.
There's one on there.
Hm?
Yeah?
It's a big one.
Yes.
When you start feeling
that tug all of a sudden,
it's an indication
there's a conger.
That's heavy on there.
Get up.
You can feel it.
Wow.
[non-english speech]
That's a big one.
I'm talking about a
girth of your knee.
I mean, they're thick,
and they're strong,
and they're powerful.
There's another one.
There's another
one down there.
Yes, it's a big one.
It's a big one?
[bleep] I can feel it.
That is mahoosive.
There's one more on here.
What the [bleep] is under there?
The tug of a conger eel
with a hand line is huge.
You can really feel
that thing fighting you.
That's heavy on there.
[bleep] There is that adrenaline
because you're pulling like mad
and you can feel
it tug, tug, tug.
Here she comes.
He's coming.
It's tugging like mad.
GORDON RAMSEY: (VOICEOVER)
This line isn't budging.
David says eels
here can wait nearly
30 pounds, which is much
bigger than anything
I've pulled in so far.
That is massive.
It's a big one.
Wow.
That's a beauty.
The size of that thing.
GORDON RAMSEY: (VOICEOVER) After
my Croatian Cross Fit workout,
I'm definitely
ready for a break.
Oh.
GORDON RAMSEY:
(VOICEOVER) I just
hope my arms have enough
strength left to lift the eel
from my plate to my mouth.
We made some conger eel pate.
Mm.
It's silky--
Wow.
--and very tasty,
a little bit buttery.
I had no idea
it can be finessed
to that level of a pate.
It's really good.
Our limit in the kitchen, you
know, it's all in our heads.
An amazing start to my
journey, let me tell you.
I'll come back at the end of the
week and we'll cook together.
Yeah?
I'll give you a
run for your money.
Thank you.
Now can you get me
off this bloody boat?
I never thought a conger
eel could set the bar.
Based on the flavor
of that pate,
I think this guy has got
other tricks up his sleeve.
This is going to be
a tough final cook.